what truce there was here ended this
morning
protestors behind him made shields will
king in two live fire even after this
man is knocked off his feet
the dates cover and corazon
the police are shooting directly at
protesters they're using snipers to with
high-velocity rifles firing from
positions among the trees the protesters
are pushing up towards the government
district armed here with Molotov
cocktails almost setting themselves on
fire but we saw handguns and shotguns
too there are casualties on both sides
police here dragging is seriously
injured colleague away the protesters
are running they're wounded back on
makeshift stretchers they're heading
here to a hotel lobby now being used as
a field hospital volunteer medics in
hard hats doing what they can we filmed
patients with critical injuries this man
with a gunshot wound to the chest
man killing another with a gunshot wound
to the groin
a priest kneeling by his side on the
phone to his family in the corner a
man's body covered by a blanket giving
him what dignity they can there's little
time here for ceremony outside they're
painting a red cross on a white sheet to
hang from the door above they're marking
red crosses on their helmets too there
have been reports of medics being
deliberately targeted a 21 year old
volunteer one of their colleagues was
shot dead today
this is escalating rapidly and they're
preparing for the worst the sanctions on
the visa level visas level it's good but
you need to arrest accounts of those
guys because Yanukovych is not going
down without taking very many many many
dead people with him people just try to
take border to support border because I
heard that a lot of police concentrate
around and try to come to key from other
regions down in Independence Square the
bodies are laid out in the street
they're covering them with blankets and
the Ukrainian flag
the opposition say the authorities
started this and it is moving now beyond
their control the protesters were filmed
leading a long line of riot police away
it's not clear where they were taking
them 67 officers are currently reported
to be missing as darkness falls here
there resupplying a human chain of young
and old passing bricks dug from the
pavement to the front they're using
these bricks no to build a wall here to
shore up their defenses on this site
behind them they have fire extinguishers
raining to go Molotov cocktails crate
full on the ground and new supplies of
tires which they are setting on fire on
the far side of this barricade
attempting to create a smoke screen
between them and the police they don't
know what's yet to come here but they
are determined to stand their ground
Katie stalard Sky News Kiev